hi guys itself right again and I would
like to introduce you to theme parks to
do or probably most of my subscribers
are going to know about this game anyway
because it's pretty hyped at the moment
I think and it just came out an hour ago
and seem something like that but I want
to be one of the first people to do this
just took the game and just opened it
and I was like what the [ __ ] do I do
with this I was very confused now first
of all I just looked at all the options
just clicks all the buttons because
that's what silver at does when he gets
a new program or game he just clicks all
the buttons and eventually the program
crashes which is what happened it
crashed I got it to crash within 30
minutes so that was cool and now I'm
here again and I'm going to record again
because I was already I already had made
that little let's play and made it that
little let's play but it was it was
terrible because of course I I was just
messing around and crushing the game and
everything so I lost everything but I am
back and I'm going to introduce you to
this game so if you like voila question
3 but you don't like really cascoon one
or it's going to or you maybe like
everything but you're just very much
into sandbox games and more into the
simulation and creative aspects than the
economic aspect and managing and stuff
like that and then this is the right
game for you I suppose though at the
moment it's okay I'm going to have to be
honest sorry
Pantera entertainment it's kind of
shitty at the moment but of course it's
a work in progress but I'll just run you
through this entire game very much like
low-mid nuts low limits no limits you
can just pick a nice sky that you like
and nice background like mountains which
look very awesome and we've also got
some night sky different night sky with
not the skybox with Distin and I really
like a distance so that's cool and now
there's one very strong thing about this
game which totally beats Rolla cuscan 3
if you ask me and that is the way that
paths work because you've got this one
option over here and you can just take a
path with sidewalks and everything and
you can even design your own paths
I think not too sure about how that
works himself but you can do it I can
see that this game does not want seem to
want to responders do something as you
can see it's very laggy so that's not
very good and it's not my computer I
think it's fraps is still saying 14
frames per second I can still move my
camera and now it's moving on some kind
of grid which I don't know what is stop
doing this
delete path the leads I sad to lead just
got rid of it yes okay anyway the way
paths work is like this you just have
some nodes and they connect like this
but you can make the curves diff curves
different as well I think it's some kind
of option that I clicked on because I
can also make perfectly straight paths
and they're also neon in some kind of
grits even these curves are which is
very handy but I don't know how to go
back into the free kind of control thing
anyway this looks cool and we've got
path library with things and build which
I don't know what it is I won't touch
that we've got some benches absolutely
amazing benches actually some very nice
benches I mean the models of all these
paths things are actually really good
nice blue and standing here which is a
really nice very nice lamp not much else
yet though but of course with custom
scenery and everything like that people
are still going to be making that yeah
basically the controls are like this if
you want to rotate your camera you have
to press control and just move your
mouse to run the screen and it does this
and a heart annoying so yeah I prefer
using Q and E so that's just a little
pro tip for you guys and these models
actually look pretty good and I really
like the way shadows and light work and
lights work in this game so that's very
good point about this and then moving on
we've got shops and buildings you can
just take this castle for example
oh god oh god okay forecastle just place
it there and look look at my skill look
at this I'm such a great seriously this
many flags yeah I would kind of got rid
of a few flags because this is this is
ridiculous I think this is actually the
castle they used in the industry but
this burger stand sure is really cool oh
I like that
nice model now we've got trees and we've
got some beautiful trees so far we've
got this Aspen which is useless we've
got all these down under trees which
this one is pretty cool this one is less
cool we've got the ginkgo biloba which I
it's not even how you pronounce it
sounds kind of kinky and we've got the
Japanese maple tree which is always nice
except in this game for some reason it's
really tiny but whatever and other
things these are pretty cool these small
ones I figured you could use them along
the sides of paths like this and then
there are some other these this second
pine I really like this second fine to
be honest it's really nice and we've got
flower org in here so you could place
that over there
I don't know and then we've got a flower
patch which is terrible
well not terrible but it's it's me mm
yeah it's terrible I do like these
flower rings though they're pretty cool
and we've got some house rings as well
of course these look awesome
I just by the way in this game are great
though this hedge isn't as fantastic
look at that it just looks like they
took one hatching and just took the
dragon copy tool and just machine gun to
hedges everywhere and make this kind of
an abomination moving on we've got
flared rise we've got this carousel got
all these cool things this carousel is
actually really cool actually it's not
that impressive
this is this poll looks kind of thin
otherwise it's good
these models really look like they're
models like okay guys you're going to
have to make your own flat rise but
we'll just provide you with a few crappy
flat rights just because we have to
because otherwise this wouldn't be a
game I don't know what it is and we
forgot some nice little lights we've got
the blue Omni fast render not sure what
that means it doesn't seem to want it
your mid light so let's try turning the
night sky on and light that's really
cool that's good I like the way that
light works actually a lot better than
in Roy Chris green three well we just
create little glitchy blocks and
everything and then we can create our
own things and I've no idea how this
works but I'm pretty sure you should be
able to import things but I'm not sure
how might might discover that later on
and that we've got oh oh this is going
to this is going to make you laugh just
look at this fire going to place this
fire right and this is this is my big
square torch I'm going to place it on
top of this torch look at that good
animation is what I what I thought at
first I mean the animation does look
good but see the thing is you can oh I'm
moving this thing oh I didn't want to do
that actually see that yeah you see that
this is little line over here where the
particle just disappears might want to
fix that guys and I discovered I can
actually click things now that's nice I
mean you can select things and then you
can have the rotate tool and I mean the
move to over it will the rotate tool
very very nice scale objects which is
also very handy because you might want
to scale things wait okay okay guys I've
had enough of this that's not good you
can scale a down those scaling it down
is okay but apparently making things
bigger just doesn't work because you've
got this kind of crap do I really have
to put up with this
that so that's about it we've got some
interesting what are things but this is
basically the gameplay of this game good
then these things and we've got some
know this this is interesting old [ __ ]
this is awesome
I mean if with enough effort I mean
people have made this using the current
version of the game so I thought at
first the game was kind of crappy but
it's very promising and just look what
you can do if you're not as stupid as I
am I mean this is nothing serious yet
but if I look at this then of course
I've might doubts about this game of
course I'm kind of skeptical but this
sure does look promising and if just
with enough effort because I just got
this game I can create things better
than this and import things and had
endless possibilities this is very
promising game so what I'd say at the
moment is this game looks very promising
and I think in the future it's going to
be very useful and handy but as of now
it's just not as good so if you're in
doubt mmm I would recommend not getting
it yet
or just not not anyway but but if you
really think this is going to be awesome
just get steam and download this thing
and yeah I had two things with anyway
that was this episode of the last play I
have no idea why it that this I just
wanted to give you a little review and
gameplay of this game and I hope that I
can continue this series with some
actual curda gameplay with me building
things just like I do in Mullica squad 3
so till then guys